(audience cheering)
- It's nice to see you.
- It's so nice to see you too.
- I was asked several
times if we'd ever met,
and I was like,
"I don't think so."
- We've met three times.
- [Kelly] No, we have not.
- No, I'm kidding.
- Oh my God.
I was like, "Oh my God."
I was like-
- They asked me the same
and I feel like we have,
but I just feel like-
- It might have been in passing then,
because they asked me too.
They always ask me
because I've been in the industry
doing other things, right?
- [Jake] Yes.
- So I'm like, "I don't think so."
But I don't know,
it might have been in
passing or something.
But if you don't really remember
and I don't remember-
- Then we definitely have.
- Maybe we just see each other in things
and we're like,
"We know each other."
- Yeah, no,
I think I see you on TV.
You have a TV show, right?
- Yeah, little bit.
- Okay, I think maybe that's probably it.
- Yeah, that's probably it, yeah.
Do you ever do that, by the way?
Have you ever run into someone
and you're like,
you think you know them
and then you figure out
they're someone in a film or something?
- Oh, always.
- [Kelly] Okay, that's
totally happened to me.
- All the time.
- I didn't say anything, but like,
I was in an elevator and I was like,
"I- Nope, you don't know that person."
And it's like, don't say anything,
you don't know them.
Wait, I just mentioned "City Slickers"
which is one of my favorite movies.
I know it's a long time ago for you.
- That's never been mentioned
on anything I've ever-
- Are you serious?
- [Jake] Yeah.
It's very rarely talked
about in the oeuvre,
you know what I mean?
- I thought I was going to be
that annoying person that asks you
about the films you're
asked about all the time
since you were a kid, okay.
- I mean, kind of.
It's a very special movie
for me because it's-
- Me, too, I love that movie so much.
- [Jake] Yeah.
- And I just thought it was so crazy.
So how did you end up doing that movie?
You were young, right?
- I was 11, yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- [Jake] I know,
it's the first thing I ever did was,
I was 11 years old.
- [Kelly] Your first thing ever to do
was with that cast?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Sure.
- Pretty incredible, I know.
Well, it's weird.
- Life.
It's like, wow.
- Well it's weird
because my parents made movies
and you know,
my mother's a writer
and so there was a night
Billy Crystal was
actually at our house and-
Yeah, yeah,
and I was 10 or something like that.
And at the end of dinner
everyone was leaving
and I was just so enamored by him,
you know, like I was like,
"Oh my God, it's Billy."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I just picked up a chair
and I offered it to him as a parting gift.
(audience laughs)
I was like, "Here's a party favor."
I like handed him the chair,
and he thought it was so funny,
and I was just wanting
to give him a chair.
- Just genuine, like, "Take this."
- I just didn't know what,
you know when someone's like,
and you just want to give them something
and you're like,
"Just take, take it."
You know what I mean?
And that's how I was and he loved it.
- "A souvenir of this dinner."
- Basically.
And he was like,
"That kid's got something special."
(Kelly laughs)
Little did he know, but yeah.
- Oh my God, that's amazing.
- He was like, "Come audition
for this new movie that I'm doing
because I need someone to play my son."
And then I did,
and then I got the part.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- Yeah.
- Did you ever have any real jobs,
like regular jobs?
(Jake laughing)
Like I mean,
wait for it.
I just heard it.
- No, no, no, no.
No, no,
it makes total sense, by the way-
- I mean, like, in life,
like a normal average-
I've had a lot of like normal jobs.
- You're just digging-
No, no, of course.
You're right.
- Being an actor is not-
You play, it's fun.
It's being a musician, same thing.
- Yeah, I agree.
- Yeah.
Not fake, but-
- Yeah. But we do.
No, but I mean,
I'm not like actually playing someone,
I'm not in the military,
I'm not actually playing,
I'm not that thing,
I'm playing it.
So it is a little not real, but-
- [Kelly] I just meant like a normal job.
- I got it.
- Like I worked at Papa John's, man.
You ever worked at Papa John's?
- No, it's fine.
No, I didn't work at 'Papa John's',
but I was a lifeguard.
- Oh.
No, that's another real job.
(audience applauds)
- They're excited about that.
- That's another real job.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Wait, did you ever save anyone's life?
- Well, in a way, yeah.
- What does this mean?
- Well, like, I didn't,
I wasn't like "Baywatch" necessarily.
It was more like,
I guarded the beach.
Like meaning there was like a public beach
and a private beach
and I had to tell people
to not come onto the private beach.
- Oh.
(audience laughing)
You were the person to remind them
of what level they were at.
(audience laughs)
"You haven't made it here.
These are the fake people
with the fake jobs."
- "The people who are
having fun over here,
you're not allowed there."
But like, it was more like,
it was just like a mark guy,
just a boundary marker, you know?
And I most of the time
just had to get up and be like,
"Sorry,"
and then people were
just pissed, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
You were like a beach bouncer.
- Basically.
That's exactly what I was.
- Yeah.
- That's better actually.
That's what I should have said.
- Sounds cool.
- Yeah, but then I also
had to do other things
like first aid and stuff like that.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- Yeah, that was cool.
- I actually took a class,
like I know how to do CPR.
I enjoy learning stuff like that, do you?
- I do too, it's really important.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I think it's really important.
- Yeah, I think it's when I had kids.
I was like, "Don't die,"
I did everything to learn
for them not to die.
- That's a good plan.
- Yeah.
I feel like I'm killing it.
(Kelly laughs)
Killing it?
- Um.
(Kelly laughs)
- I respect that,
you're hardworking at your normal job.
- At your normal job.
(audience laughs)
At your real job.
At my fake one, we just do this.
- But the thing is, is that,
like one time
somebody got stung by a jellyfish,
like a man o' war.
- Ooh, I've been stung by a jellyfish.
- It's no fun.
- Yeah.
- Like a big one or like a tiny one?
- I don't know how big it was,
but it hurt like hell
and I had to pee on myself.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, they were like,
"You gotta pee on herself,"
and everybody's like,
"She's not gonna be able to do it,"
and I was like, going.
(audience laughs)
I was like, "Will it take away the burn?
I will pee on in front
of anyone if it will-"
- That's what I decided-
- You peed on yourself or someone?
- Well, they told me that
that was what you had to do
and a person was in pain.
(everyone laughing)
(audience cheering)
I suggested that we should use pee,
I suggested it.
And they, at that point,
you know the pain of a jellyfish sting,
they wanted it,
they'd take anything, really.
- They couldn't pee themselves, huh?
- Well, I didn't really pee on them.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay.
- We sort of took some pee in.
- Okay.
- It was their choice.
(Kelly laughing)
- I just love this.
- You do what you need to sometimes
to save a life,
you know what I mean?
(audience cheering)
- So before the break,
we were talking about your job,
your real job,
as a lifeguard,
but you were also a sous chef as well.
Do you still love to cook?
- I love cooking, yes.
- Can you get me into
that idea, that theme?
- That you like cooking?
- Yeah.
I just really want to like it.
And I go in there,
and there's like two things I make
that I'm like, "Cool."
But like,
I just really wanna be into it.
What got you into it?
- I think,
well my family all cooked together
when I was a kid.
- Oh, well.
- And my dad did a lot of cooking,
and my mom did too.
My dad did mostly the warm food cooking
and my mom did the cold food cooking.
Like, she would make a killer salad
and then my dad would make like,
you know,
protein or whatever.
- [Kelly] Steak.
- Steak, yeah.
But we always got along best at the table,
you know?
It was like the conversations we'd have
and the food, we all love food.
So I started to just love it.
I don't really know where it came from.
I just love eating.
So then I was like-
- Well, I'm into that part.
I love that part.
I just, I can't-
I'm trying,
and we do so many cooking
things on the show.
- Yeah.
- And I'm trying to get into it,
but every time I get in there I'm like,
"Or I could read."
- [Jake] You don't have to.
This is the thing.
I think that there's a
lot of pressure on that-
- I could have wine.
- Yeah.
I do think there's a lot of pressure
on needing to be able to cook somehow.
And I don't know what it is.
And you gotta love it.
- I feel like I might.
Are you healthier though because of it?
That's why,
I feel like people that I know that cook
are generally really healthy.
- Yeah.
- I'm not like a shiny example of that.
So like, I think-
- You're not healthy?
- No.
I eat really good things
but I also really love bad things.
- Yeah.
But you can cook bad things.
- And like with good ingredients?
- Well, if you love something
you can be like, "Oh, I love this thing
and then I'm gonna find the ingredients."
It doesn't have to be
really good ingredients,
you just start cooking it
and then you're like, "Oh,
I'm gonna try it this way
and try it that way,"
and then you just do it differently
and then it changes stuff.
You know?
- I have tried several times
with healthy ingredients,
and sometimes I'm like, "No."
- No. Yeah.
It's funny you say that
'cause I tried to bake
this thing the other day
that's in this amazing-
- I love baking.
- Yeah. Baking.
- I do love baking.
Not cooking.
- Well, it's sort of the same-
- Different.
- I mean, it's sort of-
- [Jake] I'm not gonna
argue with you there.
I feel like that's a very sensitive-
- It takes no thought.
- That's not true.
- No, I feel like it's-
- All the bakers in the
world just went like,
"It takes no thought?"
- No, it takes like-
(audience laughs)
"You're in a fake job."
- Yeah.
"You fake baker!"
- I feel like because with cooking
you're like, a dab, a splash of,
you know, a pinch.
And I'm like, that's relative.
- Oh, meaning you need measurements.
- [Kelly] I need the chemistry.
- What's fake about that?
And all the scientists hate you too now.
- I need the recipe
and I can follow it to tee
and I'm good at baking.
- Yeah.
I mean, I understand.
I think baking's really hard.
I think it's harder than that.
- Oh, I love baking.
- [Jake] Well, there we go.
- I'm good at that, okay.
- [Jake] Now we got a competition.
- What did you bake though?
- I baked this like,
flowerless chocolate meringue cake.
- Ooh, I love meringue.
- [Jake] From this amazing
book by this woman,
Claire Saffitz.
- Meringue is hard.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh, shut up.
(audience laughs)
- No.
- Meringue is so hard for me.
- I mean-
- I screw it up.
- How do you do it?
- Not well.
- Do you use an electric mixer
or do you use a whisk?
- I've done both.
I've done both.
I literally lost a competition
to my tour manager once on a pie
because of the meringue.
It was a sad meringue.
- Really?
- Yeah.
What did you do, though?
Did you use like a healthy ingredient
that didn't work out or something?
- Well, yeah, I tried.
- That's what I did.
- I tried coconut sugar,
which is just a real no-go
for an egg white.
Sometimes you just need the bad stuff.
You just need regular sugar.
- I do like monk fruit.
I dunno if you've ever used that.
- Monk fruit's wonderful.
I love monk fruit.
Yeah.
You need to go for,
you know, real sugar,
it really makes those
stiff peaks, you know?
And that's what you need for a meringue,
you know what I mean?
- I used real sugar,
I just sucked at it.
So your new movie,
since you're not an actual chef-
- Or do anything normal.
Yeah, it's fine.
No big deal.
- Since you have no real job.
- It was hard to walk out here.
I don't how I got out here.
- I'm so sorry.
So your new movie,
it's called "The Covenant".
So can you tell everybody what it's about?
- [Jake] Yeah.
It's a story about
a special operations sergeant
and an Afghan interpreter
who sort of become
likely kind of connected.
And basically it's a story
about repaying a debt.
You know?
It's a story about one guy
who does something for the other one,
basically saves his life,
and in the end, you know,
despite what he wants to do,
my character goes and saves his.
And I think that's like,
it's a very simple story
but it's a parable about
two people just doing good
despite themselves,
which I love because I think
you can sentimentalize doing good a lot.
Like, "Oh you-"
- Do what you know is right.
- Yeah.
And like sometimes you do it begrudgingly.
Sometimes you're like, "Ugh."
You know?
And I love that about it,
'cause I think that speaks
to the best parts of us
that we don't even know
are the best parts of us.
You know?
And that's what the movie's about.
- So you were into
music and music theater,
and you worked
with Stephen Sondheim once, right?
- I did, yeah.
- [Kelly] What did you do with him?
- We did "Sunday in the Park with George".
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
That's so cool.
(audience applauds)
I love this picture.
(Jake and Kelly laughing)
- It literally looks
like a paparazzi fight,
I'm like, "Did we work together?"
Or was I trying to get a picture with him?
- "Did you meet him?"
- Yeah. Yeah.
I'm like, "Take the picture now,
he's passing by."
- So you do know him.
- I did know him.
I think that picture
was taken opening night.
Yeah, I mean,
he's a legend, you know.
I mean, he loved puzzles, you know,
that was the most amazing thing about him.
- What kind?
Like putting them together or like Sudoku?
- All different puzzles.
- Okay, me too.
I love crossword.
- Yeah.
He loved crosswords.
But, like,
any puzzle he could get his hands on,
and his songs, his lyrics,
and his storytelling
is all like a puzzle.
So like when you were performing
anything he was doing,
you always constantly every night
trying to unpick the
puzzle for the performer
as you were trying to figure it out,
and then the audience was too.
So there was never a night
where I wasn't like,
"Oh-oh, where am I going?"
He's fooling you with the music.
He's fooling you with the lyrics.
He's playing with you.
- [Kelly] Beautiful mind.
- He was just an incredible man.
- Yeah.
That's so cool how people think like that
and put things together
and you can see the show a million times
and come out thinking something different.
- You can do it a million times.
- Yeah.
- The thing you realize, I think,
as a performer in that space is that,
you can feel so different every night,
and you can add things to it,
but in the end
the story is always in charge, you know?
It's always moving the audience.
And it humbles you,
'cause I think you can come out
and be like, "Oh, I was so-"
I remember in rehearsal once,
I was rehearsing something
with the other actor,
and we came off stage and went,
"Oh, that was the best thing we've ever-
Ugh, amazing performance.
Like, we just felt so connected."
And the director came back and went,
"That was so slow and boring."
You know?
- Like, just handed you some truth?
- "Just speed it up.
Just tell the story."
And the next night we were like,
"Just shave five minutes off,
speed up the pace and let's go."
And we did
and we felt so weird about it,
and she came back weeping
at the end after that.
- Isn't it weird?
- The way in which as a performer
what you feel is not always
what you guys feel
so incredible as an experience.
It's so humbling.
Like, to me.
- And it's different every time,
that's what I love about it.
You've actually been
in quite a few music videos as well,
so I have to ask you, like,
how did you end up,
this is amazing,
you were in "Blame It"
with Jamie Foxx and T-Pain.
How did that-?
What was that, like-?
Did they just call you?
- [Jake] I have no idea, Kelly.
I don't know how I got into that.
- This is incredible.
- Jamie Foxx, you know,
he's like-
- I love Jamie.
- He's so great.
And he just called me up,
and he was like,
"I clearly was at a
loss of finding people."
I was like, probably last.
I was like-
I mean, Gyllenhaal,
G's not far down
but it's definitely end of the Gs,
and he had gotten all through
A, B, C, D, E, F,
you know?
Of all of Hollywood people.
And he got there.
Well yeah, clearly,
because Ron Howard's in it also.
- I know.
And Forest Whitaker.
It was like,
that's what I'm saying.
- Yeah.
So I'm just saying,
like how do you get-?
So it's Ron Howard, me,
Jamie Foxx and Forest Whitaker in a car,
in a Hype Williams directed video.
And it starts off and like,
he even got me to drive
his Bentley and like
somehow I thought I
was gonna wear this hat
and it was like cool-looking,
and I just like, again,
Jamie's like,
"You drive, you drive."
And I was like,
"Okay. I drive."
And it was in slow-mo.
And the beginning of the
video starts with us,
the four of us rolling up to a club.
Like?
- [Kelly] Like 'cause how y'all would do.
- Like the way Jamie, Ron Howard,
and Forest Whitaker and I
would always roll up to a club together.
Right?
- [Kelly] Love it.
- And it was in slow-mo,
but I had to hit a mark
and there were these sandbags
for the car to hit,
so I hit the mark right for the camera.
- Yeah.
- And I just was not
familiar with the car,
and every time I roll up in slow-mo,
the car would hit the sandbag
and we would all sort of jolt forward.
- In slow-mo?
- In slow-mo.
So if you see the video,
it's like us, like,
I'm just like trying to be hard
and I'm just like rolling like this,
and it starts
and it's just all of us going.
(audience laughs)
Like, right before.
It was great.
It was actually honestly great.
- Oh my God, I love that.
'Cause what's funny
is when they do the slow-mo,
usually they play the track really fast.
- Yeah. That's true.
- So they're playing in a music video
and they play the track extra fast,
especially when you're doing the lyrics,
you have to be like
really fast and duh-duh,
then it slows it down.
- This was the intro.
So it wasn't even that.
You can't even give me that.
I just couldn't drive the car.
- That's amazing.
- It was so sad.
- Oh my God.
We need to take a break.
- Okay.
- And I need to learn how to cook.
Okay.
But because Jake and I are both,
we both love music,
we've got a game of
"Sing That, Name That
Tune" coming up next.
I'm gonna kick your ass.